all right my next grievance is China why
do we continue to do any business with
them they lied to us on Cova they're
committing genocide president Aji is
practically best friends with Vladimir
Putin we learned yesterday that bite
dance the Chinese owned parent company
of tick tock is spying on U.S
journalists and today the CCP issued a
warning to the United States about
bullying them the Chinese foreign
minister reportedly telling the
Secretary of State blinken in a phone
call that the United States must not
continue the old routine of unilateral
bullying and we must pay attention to
Chinese legitimate concerns stop Curbing
and suppressing its development and not
constantly challenge China's Red Line in
a quote salami slicing way
here now is Gordon Chang he's Gatestone
institute's senior fellow and author of
The Great U.S China Tech War uh Gordon
uh you're you're so good on China tell
me give me your impression your thoughts
on this latest Revelation in these uh
this rhetoric coming out of China
well first of all China doesn't have
legitimate concerns it's not a
legitimate State and we should stop
treating it as such because as you say
it is committing genocide crimes against
humanity it deliberately spread covid-19
Beyond its borders that's 6.7 million
people outside of China who have died
from a disease that should have never
left the central part of that country
you know we could go on and on but
clearly China is engaging in a series of
Acts which are destructive not only
towards the United States but the
International Community as a whole and
oh by the way Chinese leader Xi Jinping
thinks he's the world's only legitimate
ruler and that moon and Mars are part of
the People's Republic of China I don't
know you know it's just inconceivable
that we're dealing with China in a way
that we have
but it doesn't appear as if President
Biden is taking a tough stance is it is
it enough are they are we speaking the
right language so to speak to China to
try to have them say hey wait we better
not mess uh with the United States
because it was certainly that way under
President Donald Trump the waters were
calm because they understood that where
Donald Trump stood
yes and and what Biden is trying to do
is he's trying is he says to find areas
of cooperation with China and because of
that we are not promoting our own
interests we're not defending our own
country you know you pointed out that
Biden has had these five uh phone and
video conferences with Xi Jinping and
one in-person chat last month at the G20
and he has never raised the issue of the
origins of covid-19 that's 1.1 million
Americans almost that have been killed
by this disease I mean that's an
abrogation of his most solemn and
fundamental constitutional Duty which is
to defend the United States from foreign
attack so you're absolutely right
um Biden just uses the wrong language
he's not raising and not defending the
United States this is an abomination
well and what's a Rita make of tick tock
I mean we hear a lot about it they make
fun videos you watch them they're pretty
entertaining
um but uh you know they're used as a
spying mechanism that's the allegation
and yet there has been almost there's
been more action in the states than
there hasn't been in the federal
government
yes well president Trump banned
Tick-Tock along with WeChat
um President Biden one of the first
things he did was he reversed that bad
we know that over a course of years
about three or four of them Tick Tock
has been making representations to the
U.S about how it doesn't allow data to
be sent to China and it's violated every
single Assurance that's given to the U.S
but it's not just stealing data it is
actually more serious that it is using
the tick tock algorithm to uh
disseminate Chinese propaganda
glorifying drug use promoting violence
on American streets and this year
disseminating Russian narratives about
the Ukraine war so this really is an
attempt to undermine and actually even
overthrow the US government and why
we've repented permitted I don't know
India banned Tick Tock we should do the
same thing
yeah and we haven't even begun to talk
about fentanyl the other things flowing
into this country Gordon thank you I
really do appreciate joining us tonight
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else